Devil fruits are one of my favorite parts
of One Piece!
And apparently they are yours too because
you all submitted nearly TWO THOUSAND SUBMISSIONS
to my devil fruit contest.
And there were SO MANY incredible options
to choose from that I just couldn’t stop
at one video so here are twenty more of your
most MIND-BLOWING devil fruits that should
absolutely exist in One Piece.
Starting with one of the most creative ideas
I’ve ever heard of which is the Tattoo devil
fruit submitted by Ethan.
Basically, this ability allows you to draw
tattoos all over your body and then turn those
tattoos into real actions.
For example, imagine you drew a sword tattoo
on your arm.
Well, when you need a slicing attack you simply
use that sword tattoo and it appears as a
slicing attack to cut down your enemies.
Or imagine you drew a giant pair of wings
on your back.
Then using THAT tattoo would allow you to
fly for a short period of time.
So yeah, an incredibly useful fruit in almost
any situation as long as you have the creativity
and skill to draw many different tattoos.
Now to make this fruit fair, a good restriction
is that once you use a tattoo it disappears
from your body.
So no, you can’t just infinitely spam that
sword tattoo you drew.
That also means you are going to have to be
careful about which tattoos you use.
Also, another incredible ability of this fruit
could be that the larger you draw the tattoo
the more powerful it becomes.
For example, imagine you drew a wave tattoo
to send out water.
Well, if the tattoo is small like as big as
your hand, then it probably would just be
a small burst of water.
But then imagine that you drew the wave across
your entire chest, well, then you might get
a giant tsunami to wash away all of your opponents.
So yeah, these are exactly the kinds of creative
fruits I love to see that can be used in combat
but also in so many other situations.
However, even the tattoo fruit would likely
get overwhelmed by the sheer power of the
Sound devil fruit submitted by Gelo Boi Is
Cool.
And this one is just all kinds of powerful
because this Logia fruit transforms you into
a Sound Wave human capable of becoming AND
producing all types of sound waves.
And at first you might be thinking, well that
doesn’t sound so cool, but TRUST ME.
THIS FRUIT IS INSANE!
Because sound waves are literally EVERYWHERE,
ALL THE TIME.
So this user can obviously send out sound
waves to make crushing sonic booms or they
can make different voices all around to confuse
people.
You also get incredible speed because you
can travel at the speed of sound.
That’s not all though because if your sound
waves are strong enough they can even act
like a physical attack to knock people down,
kinda like how you can feel the air vibrating
in front of a super loud speaker.
But to get to the most broken part of this
fruit, we need to dive into science for just
a moment because recent research has even
shown that people’s brains can be somewhat
controlled by certain sound waves.
So yeah, an extremely skilled user of this
fruit can possibly even influence a person’s
behavior to a certain extent.
However, there is one major drawback and that
is because sound waves can be blocked by physical
objects, so this fruit can be majorly nerfed
if the target is hiding behind a wall or something.
So while that may keep some people away from
the sound fruit, I can’t think of anyone
who wouldn’t want this next fruit.
That’s because Pete Culver from the United
States submitted the Kibo Kibo no mi, otherwise
known as the Wish fruit.
And just like it sounds, this is the classic
genie in a bottle ability which grants the
user exactly three wishes.
And man what a RIDICULOUS POWER because with
this fruit you could literally take over the
world.
Want to become ruler of the world government?
Just wish for it.
Or how about becoming the richest person in
the world?
Easy.
Or you want to own one of the strongest weapons
in the world?
Done.
But as cool as this fruit is, we just have
to include some restrictions such as you can’t
just wish for someone to be dead.
No wishing for the ability to swim, since
that defeats the main weakness of a devil
fruit.
No wishing for more wishes or something that
completely breaks reality.
Oh yeah, and you have to be super specific
about your wishes.
For example, if you just wish for something
like super strength, well this fruit can give
you that, but it might not be exactly what
you were hoping for.
Because sure you can have super strength,
but maybe only for five seconds.
In the right hands though, and with some careful
wishing, this fruit could easily help you
take over the world.
What’s crazy though is that this next fruit
might be even better than the Wish fruit in
the hands of the right person.
Because now we have the Build fruit submitted
by Flopo from Germany.
And just like it sounds, this fruit allows
the user to build anything they can imagine
as long as they have the right materials nearby.
Which is SO USEFUL.
I mean with this fruit if you are somewhere
like Marineford with lots of stone, metal,
guns, and swords everywhere you could make
yourself a giant mech suit full of slashing
blades and powerful guns.
And if that’s not enough, you could turn
the stone beneath you into a giant castle
for defense.
But this fruit is even more useful outside
of battle because it could also make you filthy
rich.
For example, you instantly become the world’s
best one-man construction company where you
can make houses, buildings, or even this world
government’s giant bridge with incredible
speed.
However, one downside of this fruit is that
you can’t really change your available resources
too much, so you basically use what you’ve
got.
However, just wait until you see another power
in just a minute that will make the Build
fruit look like a child’s construction kit.
First though, we have the first of many super
creative Zoan fruits with the Gecko fruit
submitted by Brendan from the United States.
And now at first this may sound a bit disappointing,
but just listen to the incredible abilities
that Geckos possess.
First, they get the obvious normal zoan abilities
like a full Gecko form and a Gecko-human hybrid
form.
And alongside this you get the ability to
climb walls with your sticky hands.
Your Gecko body instantly becomes poisonous
to touch because many Geckos are covered with
poisonous slime.
Along with this you can shoot out poison at
enemies, look in two different directions
at once, and use enhanced hearing.
But on top of all that, there are two incredible
abilities that also make just way too much
sense with this fruit.
First, lizards are well known to be able to
regenerate parts of their body, so a slow
regeneration ability would make a lot of sense
with this fruit.
Plus we could also give it a camouflage power
since many lizards are experts at blending
in with their environments.
And that extra stealth factor makes it perfect
for someone like a secret agent or a sneaky
character like Sanji.
However, there’s probably no sneakier fruit
than this next one which is the Phase devil
fruit submitted by S-Stinger from Canada.
And to explain this fruit, basically think
of yourself like a ghost where you can turn
your body into an untouchable substance.
This ability would let you walk through walls
with ease, sink into the ground, and pop back
up in another place, and even make you immune
from most normal attacks since they would
just pass right through you.
And man can you just imagine someone literally
just popping out of a wall or the ground?
It’d be like the ultimate jump scare ability.
On top of that though it is great for sneaking
around and gathering information.
Enemies also wouldn’t be able to hit you,
although it’s not great for attacking because
you also can’t hit anything while you are
in your untouchable state.
However, the awakening of this fruit could
really unlock its full potential.
Because if the user awakens this fruit they
would be able to give their phase ability
to any object around them.
So if a friend is trapped in handcuffs, you
can Phase them right out.
And this would be even more perfect for a
sniper like Usopp who could even make his
projectiles pass through walls to hit enemies
on the other side.
Now, this next fruit is going to take things
to an entirely new level.
That’s because Kiefster’s Summon Summon
no mi is an ability that lets you summon creatures
to fight for you in battle.
And this is a pretty common ability that we’ve
seen in other anime, but essentially this
fruit would let you call out monsters or other
creatures to fight for you.
Classic magic user, just sits back and lets
others fight for them.
But what’s cool about this power is that
you would start off with some basic creatures
that you can summon, but as you get stronger
and better with the fruit then those creatures
evolve to become terrifying monsters on the
battlefield.
Another special ability that makes this fruit
unbelievably awesome is that you can make
contracts with other animals you find in the
world so that you can summon them as well.
And can you just imagine a master of this
fruit summoning a whole force of the most
powerful creatures in the world?
Giant lions, gorillas, snakes, even sea kings.
Truly, mastering this fruit makes you an entire
world-conquering army all by yourself.
But even summoning an entire army isn’t
even as game-changing a power as the Truth
devil fruit submitted by CJ from the United
States.
And just like it sounds, this fruit allows
you to force someone to answer your questions
truthfully.
Which is pretty simple, but let’s break
down how it actually works.
First, you must make eye contact with a person
and then you can activate your power.
This forces the person into a trance-like
state where they must answer any of your questions
for a short period of time.
So yeah, remember when this guy casually dropped
a hint about the National Treasure of Mary
Geoise and we all desperately wanted to know
more?
Well with this fruit, you could simply make
him tell you everything that he knows about
the treasure.
And with this type of intelligence gathering
power, you would instantly become one of the
most important people in the world.
For example, just look at this guy who controls
the world’s newspapers.
He is a highly influential person because
he controls so much of the information that
gets spread around the world.
But just imagine how much more control you
could have over the world if you could find
out secret information that the world government
would never want you to share.
Though I suppose that would make you their
number one target, so maybe you would be better
to keep your powers a secret.
To take this one step further, awakening this
power allows you to fire truth bullets that
force people to tell you the truth even if
you aren’t looking right at them.
However, if that doesn’t quite seem powerful
enough for you, then just wait until you hear
about this next fruit which can literally
make you as powerful as a planet.
That’s because with the Orbit fruit submitted
by Ofir from Israel, you can manipulate the
gravitational pull of anything.
That means that instead of everything naturally
being pulled down to the earth by gravity,
you could make yourself the center of gravity
for the people and objects around you.
And just to visualize what this means, if
you make yourself the center of gravity that
means that things will start to orbit around
YOU.
So that rock sitting over there will now start
to rotate around you.
And the same goes for people or other objects,
so you could have a ton of people or stuff
who are naturally pulled around you like your
own little planet.
Of course, you can also make other things
the center of gravity, but where the power
of this fruit truly lies is being able to
quickly change the center of gravity to confuse
opponents AND even change the speeds at which
things orbit.
This would let you gather a bunch of objects
around you and then shoot them off like missiles.
So yeah, a fruit that would take A TON of
practice, but if you can master it you would
be a fighting god.
But I’d personally still rather face that
devil fruit than this next one.
Because now we have the Tero Tero no mi from
Alex Hinkley, otherwise known as the Terror
devil fruit.
And oh boy, does this give me goosebumps.
Because this devil fruit allows you to create
illusions based on your target’s worst nightmare.
So let’s imagine you are in battle and someone
is attacking you.
Well simply activate your power and you can
give them a heart attack by scaring them with
their greatest fear.
Awakening this fruit could even turn the entire
environment into a nightmare realm where you
basically paralyze your opponents with fear.
However, there is one major downside here
because the illusions aren’t really physical
so they can’t actually attack the person.
Also, if your opponent’s worst fear isn’t
something all that terrifying, like fluffy
pink bunnies or something, then your fruit
is basically worthless.
Still though, keep
this
fruit away from me.
One
fruit
that
will never be worthless though is the Eno
Eno no mi submitted by Chris.
And the idea with this fruit is that you can
empty or fill up anything.
As a simple example, let’s say you were
thirsty but your water bottle was empty.
Well, with this fruit, you can fill it back
up with your favorite drink.
Or if your fridge is running low, you can
fill it up with food.
However, one major restriction here is that
the things you “fill up” or “empty”
are only temporary, so these changes wouldn’t
last forever.
Now you might be thinking that’s a pretty
weak fruit, but the true power of this ability
comes when you move from physically filling
or emptying things to doing the same with
abstract concepts.
For example, what if you filled your enemy's
head with the idea that they were your ally,
so that they fight with you on the battlefield.
Or say someone saw you sneaking into their
fortress, well then you could “empty”
their memories of having seen you.
So yeah, anytime we get these kinds of creative
abilities are always just an instant winner
in my mind.
However, no one can argue that the Snake Snake
fruit Mythical model Boitata isn’t just
simply amazing.
And this idea from P.H Minduim from Brazil
centers around the mythological Boitata creature
from Brazilian folklore.
Basically, this is a giant snake with a few
special abilities.
First, the snake is constantly covered with
flames, so it has the ability to manipulate
fire.
In addition to that it can create optical
illusions to confuse its enemies.
But its ultimate ability is called the Eye
Devourer, which will allow the user to steal
an opponent’s vision from one eye, which
means they are blind in the one eye unless
they can defeat the giant snake within a certain
period of time.
I mean wow, what a terrifying ability.
Then on top of all the normal benefits of
zoan fruits, you are literally an enormous
snake with unstoppable power and defense,
which truly makes this fruit a devastating
combat ability.
This next fruit though is 100% the most cursed
ability in this entire video.
Because Moses D. Fraud from Italy submitted
the Dead devil fruit, which gives its user
a ton of death related powers that could completely
break the one piece world.
For example, Moses suggested that this fruit
allows the user to both communicate with the
dead AND summon the dead to fight for them.
And while the summoning part is obviously
overpowered I do think that being able to
communicate with the dead is quite important
as well.
Just imagine being able to talk with Gol D.
Roger or Joy Boy.
Seriously, just think of all the secrets you
could learn.
However, this kind of broken fruit we simply
must have restrictions.
So I think it would be fair if you can only
summon the dead if you have part of their
body or skeleton or something.
Plus, since summoning the dead is such a cursed
ability, let’s add the downside that using
this ability drains your own life as well,
which means the more you use the power the
faster you die.
Fitting for a Dead devil fruit.
Now prepare yourselves, because it is time
for the ultimate devil fruit: the Fruit Fruit
no mi or as I like to call it, the Devil Fruit
Devil fruit.
And just like it sounds, this devil fruit
allows you to create other devil fruits for
non-devil fruit users to eat.
Which is such a broken ability and sounds
like an unstoppable power for a pirate captain
to have.
However, you cannot just mass produce infinite
devil fruits though because the fruits that
you can create are only temporary.
Plus the more of these devil fruits you create
at one time, the weaker they all are.
Which means if you create one single lightning
fruit, it will be pretty close to as powerful
as the normal one, but if you make one hundred
lightning fruits at the same time, they will
all be pretty weak.
You also have to consider that the people
eating these fake fruits would be brand new
to the powers, so they aren’t going to be
masters of their powers like most devil fruit
users we see in the story.
Still, being able to have your crew switch
powers every hour or so would be insanely
cool.
You don’t get any real abilities for yourself
though, so that holds it back a bit when compared
to the unbelievable powers coming up next.
There is nothing holding back this next fruit
though because it is literally the mythical
god of the underworld.
That’s right, this is the Human Human Mythical
Zoan fruit: model Hades, which was submitted
by Benji.
And if you don’t know, Hades is the Greek
god of the underworld.
And of course we can’t include ALL of the
underworld ruler’s powers in this devil
fruit since that would be just too OP, but
we can give it the ability to summon his guardian
three-headed dog Cerberus, use his magical
helmet that turns him invisible, and maybe
some other dark magic regarding the underworld
or the dead like reviving people who have
recently died or something like that.
On top of all that, the user of the Hades
fruit would become a massive figure, kinda
like this golden Buddha here.
And of course being this big has many natural
benefits including super strength and durability,
so all together this is just one incredibly
powerful devil fruit.
However, even the God of the underworld isn’t
strong enough to compete with this next fruit,
which is actually rumored to already exist
in the one piece world.
This is the Blow Blow fruit, otherwise known
as the Wind fruit.
Now, there are different versions of this
fruit, but the one Harley from the United
States submitted is basically a wind Logia
which turns you into a wind human.
This means your body is now made of wind,
allowing you to fly.
In addition, you can produce wind to make
devastating tornadoes or wind slashing attacks.
And of course this is an unbeatable fruit
when it comes to sailing in the one piece
world, since you can steer your ship anywhere
you want to go, including in the Calm Belt.
And one thing that makes this fruit even more
impressive is its possible awakening.
For this fruit, an awakening would allow you
to control the air in the environment, and
one possible use of this is that you can suck
the air out of the area around someone making
it so they can’t breathe.
Seriously, don’t mess with air power
And with the wind powers, we are truly into
the god-tier abilities and that continues
with the Particle devil fruit submitted by
Bret from the United States.
This INSANE ability allows the user to deconstruct
and reconstruct matter into any shape or form
that they want.
Remember the build fruit we discussed earlier,
this is like that times 10 because you can
reshape the resources around you into any
shape that you want.
To put it simply, you can take a bunch of
materials and break them down into their core
element.
Then you can put them back together however
you want.
For example, if you had a pile of wooden boards,
you could break them down and reconstruct
them as one single tree.
Or if you had a giant stone castle, you could
break it down and reform it into a giant stone
cannon.
Or really whatever you wanted as long as it
is made of stone.
Which if that sounds like you need five university
degrees to use, you are probably right because
it would take A TON of practice to not mess
up every time you had to put things back together.
But man, once you figured it out, this would
be such an incredibly powerful and versatile
ability to use anywhere and anytime.
But now, we finally get to the fruit that
you’ve all been waiting for.
Because this was the number one submitted
fruit in the entire contest.
And even though I didn’t put it in the first
video, I just had to include it here.
This is of course the Water logia devil fruit,
and I chose Umar from Denmark’s submission
here.
And just like it sounds, this gives you the
ability to turn your body into water, which
lets you move around as a quick stream of
water, shoot out bursts of water, or even
create a giant flood to dominate a battlefield.
However, I do have to clarify, this fruit
doesn’t give you the ability to just control
ALL water like some people assume.
Usually for Logia’s you can only control
the substance that you produce from your own
body, so you could only control water that
you produce from your body yourself.
Which is still incredibly overpowered, but
it’s not like you could control the entire
ocean or something like that.
It’s debatable if this fruit would even
work though, since obviously water is the
main weakness of devil fruits.
But assuming it does work, then it would be
a huge advantage against any other devil fruit
user.
But even the water fruit is hard countered
by this next fruit, which is the Seal devil
fruit submitted by Wisdom from Nigeria.
Now this fruit is not this kind of seal but
instead it allows the user to seal anything,
like trapping it away.
For example, you could seal a rushing river
and then release it at the right time.
Or you could seal a door so no one can open
it.
Which honestly sounds kinda boring until you
consider that you can also seal abstract things
such as memories, movement, strength, or even
devil fruit abilities.
Which I mean come on, if you can seal those
and prevent someone from using them then this
truly is just an insanely broken fruit.
Wisdom did include some pretty fair restrictions
though.
Like you can only seal one thing at a time
and that each seal comes with a unique condition
that will break the seal.
For example, if you sealed Luffy’s strength,
then he might have to do 1000 push ups to
break the seal and use his true strength again.
Which is just awesome and exactly the kind
of creative devil fruit idea that I just love
to see.
However, nothing on this list is as creative,
broken, or useful as the Author fruit submitted
by Ricardo Cardona from the United States.
Because with this fruit you gain the ability
to summon a magical book and an area of effect
box, similar to Law’s room.
Then any story you write into the book becomes
reality within your area of effect.
So let’s say that you are fighting a really
strong opponent.
Then using your powers you can write a short
story including the character which says that
they were blinded sometime in their childhood.
Well, the magic book will literally force
the character to be blind while they are within
the area of effect.
Get the idea?
What’s more interesting about this fruit
though is that the area of effect gets larger
the more skilled the user of the fruit is,
so eventually you could influence an entire
battlefield like Marineford.
However, the strength of the fruit also depends
on the user’s skill with writing stories.
Because I can just imagine that a simpler
story might cause a weaker effect while a
more complex story would make the powers stronger.
I do wonder though what would happen if the
Author devil fruit went up against the mythical
Zodiac fruit.
Or if the Water devil fruit user had to fight
against the Blood devil fruit, and if you
want to see exactly what those fruits are
all about, you can watch the first part of
this devil contest right here.
Shanks for watching and I’ll see you in
the next one.